انضم الان الينا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه اهلا وسهلا دكتور خليل وانت تسمع
انتوني بلينكن يتحدث عن دور حاسم للامم
المتحده في حرب غزه سواء بالنسبه لعوده
المهجرين او المساعدات ما الذي يخطر
ببالك اهلا بك الا والساده المشاهدين يخطر
بالي ان هناك محاوله امريكيه لاشراك اكبر
عدد من الدول فيما يتعلق بهذه القضايا
الفلسطينيه التحدي الرئيسي هو مدى قدره
امريكا على فرض اي رؤيه قد تاتي الامم
المتحده على اسرائيل نحن اذاء حاله عجز
امريكيه واضحه هناك حاله استسلام شبه تام
من اداره بايدن للمنطق الاسرائيلي ليس
الامر فقط يتعلق بالبعد الدبلوماسي والذي
حتى هذه اللحظه هناك فشل ذريع لامريكا في
هذه المساله من خلال عدم الدعوه او
الموافقه على اي دعوه لوقف اطلاق النار بل
ايضا هذا هو الاهم ليلى الجزء المتعلق
بالدعم العسكري غير المحدود لاسرائيل حتى
هذه اللحظه نحن نتكلم الان هناك دعم عسكري
غير محدود دعم مالي في الكونجرس الامريكي
ودعم من خلال الخارجيه الامريكيه وبالتالي
حديث بلينكن يتناقض مع الافعال على الارض
وهذا الامر كل اكثر من مره نحن ازاء منطق
امريكي متناقض الى حد بعيد يقولون شيء
ويفعلون شيء اخر وبالتالي هم كما يقال
يعني يضربون انفسهم في اقدامهم او يعني دي
شذر
فوت بشكل مستمر وبالتالي هناك مشكله
حقيقيه في هذا المنطق الامريكي طيب يعني
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن كان يقف الى
جانب بلينكن وهو يقول انه يؤكد على ضروره
الضغط من اجل وقف اطلاق النار وهذا الامر
يعني الولايات المتحده هي في الموقف الذي
يستطيع ربما اكثر من اي دوله اخرى ان تضغط
به ولكن لم يحصل
اي مؤشر يدل على استعداد الولايات المتحده
للخوض في هذه النقطه تحديدا هل يمكن ان
نتوقع شيء من زيا ارته لتل ابيب هل يمكن
ان يقال شيء خلف الابواب المصدى مثلا يمكن
ان لا يقال هكذا في العالم في المؤتمرات
الصحفيه في الدول
العربيه شوف انا بشكل عام ليلى اعتقد انه
بلكن جا المنطقه من خلال من اجل عده امور
الامر الاول متعلق كما تفضلت واشرت بشكل
او باخر انه محاوله البحث في افق لهذه
المعضله العسكريه اعتقد ان الضغط الامريكي
حاليا متعلق بكيفيه الانقال من هذه الحرب
الهمجيه الواسعه الى ما يطلق عليه سن وور
يعني القيام بعمليات نوعيه باستهداف
لافراد او قاده في المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وليس من خلال القصف الهمج على الفلسطين
نتيجه لوجود تكلفه انسانيه عاليه فده
اعتقد جزء مهم جدا من نقاشات في تلبيب
الامر الاخر متعلق في ظني بمرحله ما بعد
الحرب خطط ما بعد الحرب وهذه المساله تمثل
نقطه خلاف كبيره جدا بين الطرفين
الاسرائيلي والامريكي لعده اسباب السبب
الاول متعلق ب رغبه اسرائيل والتي تم
التعبير عنها بشكل او باخر في اما عاد
تحتال القطاع مره اخرى اما رض منطقه امنيه
عازله سواء كان في الشمال او في الجنوب في
محور فيلادلفيا او حتى بناء مطنت جديده
يعني سمعنا اراء مختلفه منقبل بعض
الوزارات تقوم على تسويه غزه بالارض وبناء
بناء مستوطنات عليها الى منطقه البحر
الامر الاخر وهو الخلاف هنا ياتي فيما
يتعلق بمن يدير القطاع بعد مرحله الحرب
طبعا بافتراض ان هذه الحرب قد تسفر عن
التخلص من حماس وهذا طبعا هدف ابعد ما
يكون عن الواقع حتى هذه اللحظه هناك خلاف
حول اي دور مستقبلي للسلطه الفلسطينيه
هناك رفض اسرائيلي كامل لهذ المساله في
مقابل ذلك هناك ربما قناعه امريكيه او
رغبه امريكيه على الاقل في وجود دور لسلطه
الفلسطينيه في مرحله ما بعد الحرب
وبالتالي هناك نقطه خلاف كبيره جدا الامر
الاخر متعلق في ظني بكيفيه ضبط السلوك
الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بالبعد الاقليمي
نحن اذاء اشتعال السراح في جبهات متعدده
سواء الجبه العراقيه الجبهه اللبنانيه
والاكثر اهميه من ذلك خاصه لامريكا الجبهه
اليمنيه هناك حاله عدم استقرار بيئه
مضطربه بشكل كبير جدا في البحر الاحمر
هناك تاثير على الملاحه العالميه هناك ليف
او تشكيل لتحالف او ائتلاف يسمى حارس
الازدهار من 22 دوله تقودها امريكا وهناك
حديث حول وجود خطط امريكيه لضرب الحوثيين
داخل اليمن وهذا يعتبر تحول كبير جدا في
الصراع لانه يفتح الصراع على مصراعيه امام
سنت مختلفه اذا سمحت لي فقط اريد ان اتوقف
عند مقال النيويورك تايمز كان يتحدث عن
قيادات في النقابات الامريكيه تدعو الى
وقف فوري لاطلاق النار هذه النقابات نفسها
يعني كانت
تدعو الى موقف مختلف تماما في بدايه
الحرب هذا النوع من التغيير الحاصل داخل
الولايات المتحده هل له اي وزن ونحن نعرف
طبعا اهميه هذا التوقيت بالنسبه لبايدن
والانتخابات بالقطع له وزن كبير ليلى يعني
هناك تحول كبير جدا كما تفضلت واشرت في
معظم مكونات الشعب الامريكي سواء كان
الامر متعلق بالمجتمع المدني متعلق
بمنظمات حقوق الانسان متعلق حتى بموظفين
داخل الاداره الامريكيه الجميع يطالب بوقف
فوري لاطلاق النار نتيجه لارتفاع الباظ في
التكلفه الانسانيه في قطاع غزه نتيجه
لوجود الدعم الامريكي غير المحدود
لاسرائيل الطرف الوحيد الذي لا يسمع او
على الاقل يسمع ولا يفعل هو اداره بايدن
وهناك كما قلت اكث مره كما يبدو هناك نوع
يعني سحر اسود تمارسه اسرائيل على اداره
بايدن هناك نوع من الاستسلام شبه التام
لبايدن في هذه المساله تبني المنطق
الاسرائيلي دعم عسكري بشكل غير محدود حتى
تضحيه بمصالح الذاتيه يعني نحن نشهد تراجع
الى حد بعيد في شعبيه اكثر من استطلاع على
راي يقول ان هناك رفض ل اعاده انتخاب
بايدن في الانتخابات المقبله حتى في
انقسام داخل الحزب الديمقراطي نفسه
وبالتالي هناك منطق غير مفهوم حتى هذه
اللحظه فذا الدعم غير المحدود الاسرائيلي
من قبل اداره بايدن يعني يعني هذا ايضا
يضيف للغموض يعني ما الذي يمكن ان يجعل
بايدن يضحي بمستقبله السياسي وواضح انه
يريد ان يصبح رئيس لل لفتره ثانيه ما الذي
يجعله يمكن ان يضحي بهذه
الفرصه وال الحل يبدو بالنسبه على الاقل
لنا في العالم العربي
واضحا شوفي في اسباب مختلفه ل لهذه
المساله هذا الدعم الاعمى لاسرائيل جزء
منه شخصي وذاكر اكثر من مره هناك يعني
اعجاب من بايدن بتجربه اسرائيل في المنطقه
العربيه يعني يعني راها دوله ناجحه دوله
في المحيط من الاعداء هو لديه شخصيا نوع
من الباشن نوع من التعاطف الكبير جدا مع
تجربه اسرائيل فالبعد الشخص مهم في هذه
المساله البعد الاخر بعد استراتيجي متعلق
بانه اسرائيل تمثل حجر زاويه في رؤى
الامريكيه لمنطقه العربيه تقوم بدور ما
يطلق عليه الوتش دوج او كلب الحراسه في
المنطقه العربيه تقوم او تقوم بعمل نوع من
التوازن الاقليمي مع دول اخرى قد تكون على
غير وفاق مع امريكا كان الامر موجود في
السابق مع دوله زي مصر او مع سوريا او
العراق الان مع ايران وبالتالي تمثل
اسرائيل حليف استراتيجي مهم جدا لامريكا
بشكل كبير الامر الثالث متعلق بحسابات
داخليه انتخابيه هناك رهان من بايدن على
ما يبدو على الصوتين مهمين في هذه
الانتخابات الصوت اليهودي ليس لحجمه بل ل
تثيره المالي والاعلامي
والتعبوي في الانتخابات الصوت الاني الصوت
المتعلق باليمين المتشدد في امريكا وهذه
القاعده الانتخابيه اليمنيه تصوت في اغلب
الاحوال للجمهوريين وبالتالي هو يريد ان
يتفادى اي مزايدات من الجمهوريين على
موقفه فيقوم بدعم اسرايل بشكل غير محدود
وبالتالي هناك مجموعه عوامل داخليه
وخارجيه قد تفسر نوعا ما هذا الموقف وان
كان طبعا موقف غير مسبوق على الاطلاق في
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه اشكرك
جزيلا دكتور خليل عناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا
جزيلا